he is the head coach of the Atlanta
Falcons who also happens to be the
defensive coordinator of the Atlanta
Falcons he is Dan Quinn right here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you coach
rich I'm doing well man it's uh enjoy
being on with you two it's uh it's a
good time man training camp is here and
uh we got football in Georgia man we're
doing good you still have the now clocks
on the wall where it's on there are no
numbers it says just now it's half past
now quarter past now quarter to now you
got that stuff yeah it's a 25 now do you
do the traffic with the nows to I mean I
don't know if it's just of traffic
whether time you do it all together
on the now okay make sure where we're at
is the most important thing so man you
got a good memory brother yeah man I
look it's a it's it's just a fun thing
that I saw years ago and it's just it's
a great coaching tool I mean you know
how many times can you tell people to
focus on the moment don't look over the
steering wheel take it play-by-play I
mean that's the perfect way to do it
right
today wins a hell of a lot more than
tomorrow you know whatever you got to do
let's bust your ass get it right today
don't wait don't put it off like if you
have something you got practice they may
have been I need to see that play again
I'd rather we get another look at it
then hey let's wait till we get into
film and then we'll give another shot
tomorrow like there's another look at
something like do it now man like let's
not wait to see what it would look like
I'm feeling like let's go for it again
and see where we're at but I think when
you have that mindset like hey man go
for it
right now don't don't wait on it well if
we if we use your initials your your
your business card would read like an
eye chart dqh CDC so so are you wide you
will a defensive coordinator back to
your duties well it's you know for me
that's one of the things you know I've
got so much you know background in on
the defensive side and so I thought you
just maybe weren't you know hitting the
mark as I hoped we could and I wanted to
make sure I was going to provide you
know what that would look like and how
it should feel and so I thought at this
point no better person to do that then
to me than me excuse me because if you
don't get that far
in terms of the intensity and the way we
want to play and the tackling the
physicality the pressure on the
quarterback a lot of teams play a lot of
similar things you know the other 31
teams played three deeper man-to-man but
it just has to be the way that we play
it and I love this group and I just
wanted to make sure that we're hitting
the market in all spots and I thought
that was the way I could help the team
the best well how does that reconfigure
the way you delegate on gameday then
yeah it did a little bit and so it was
kind of a couple step process rich due
to that because in order for me to
spread you know sometime over onto the
defensive side it was going to take you
know having guys who had the experience
of Dirk cutter Mike Milwaukee and so now
he and Mike and Raheem Morris who had
you know huge background on the
offensive side Greg naps but a you know
offense coordinator for a long time so I
wanted to hire somebody that could kind
of bridge that time between game
management and defense and that person
was Bob Sutton so you know just from
coming League through the area he's
experienced like Bob's loose Martin has
perspective so when I approached them
about the position I could really you
know use is here to help partner up with
me on some of the game management things
that we could talk through and discuss
together so what was I to do which we
put a group together less Dirk myself
Bob Mike Mularkey Mahim and a few others
especially as coach and so each Tuesday
morning for an hour getting together all
around the league the game management
topics and together you know tried to
establish you know our own guidelines
and then did them all during the OTAs
and each training camp practice we try
to put the guys in as many of those
spaces as we can and so I wouldn't have
been able to do that had it not been for
guys like you know inter cutter Mike
Markkula Bob Sutton to help me in those
spaces were you know if I was going to
take on a bigger role in the defense
there wasn't going to be a spot that was
not going to get the attention it
deserved and so that's how we went about
well now Dan Quinn Atlanta Falcons head
coach here and defensive coordinator on
the Rich Eisen show now you have the
added responsibility to of deciding
whether or not to challenge pass
interference because that rule
for one year at least has been changed
I've got a liver on the head of NFL refs
I'm sure who you speak to on a somewhat
regular basis during the season in
office he's about to stroll in here in
studio our number two what is going to
be your approach philosophy on when to
throw a challenge flag on this certainly
when you've got a front row seat
especially as the HCD see a big guy you
know Richmond no.1 we kind of changed
the rule of the catch we just wanted to
have clear guidelines at what it was so
if you had two feet down or you know in
a football movement where was the third
step and I thought al and the lead
especially al and the management counsel
were very clear on what a catch is if
you remember there was a couple times
like you know all the way back to like
Dez Bryant against Green Bay like I mean
that looks like a catch and so what I
thought they did league did a really
good job of this they're very clear so
any fan or people watching it could say
that was a catch but that wasn't a catch
and so I think what people were trying
to get to with OPI or dpi how is that
going to be called and that's on allens
and the group did a very good job of
what was OPI and dpi and to their credit
they went around to every team and then
almost put you on the hot seat what do
you think yes no and you know 20 calls
together and then took all that feedback
went back met again until we all have
good guidelines for what it is I think
it's good that they didn't put it you
know was those inside of two minutes I
think that should be reviewable like
that's in the box like everything else
so I know it was a big topic and I
thought the best thing they did was make
it clear that what they were looking for
and it had better be obvious and clear
that it's either OPI or DUI and once you
know that then we have the confidence to
challenge us like you would any other
things that for us as head coaches are
challengeable so I gotta be honest with
you coach you know we were in that
position to that we being the NFL media
group when al River on came and
addressed the NFL media group symposium
in June and he did the same thing with
us hey huge show play is this offensive
pass interference defensive pass
interference would you throw a flag in
real time would you
one down through replay would you pick
one up through replay and there was no
consensus and you know obviously we
watched a football for a living but we
also had Hall of Fame players and Hall
of Fame receivers and defenders in that
room and we never agreed on it once not
a second time if it's not clear then it
shouldn't be one that can be overturned
and so that's to me where God I'm glad
that you guys did that exercise threw
back because it was definitely it's
tough one your left and when you when
you have the one that says I don't know
well if there's one that's like I don't
know then it's not right so were you a
coach that raised your hand during
whatever meetings amongst the coaches or
competition committee or at the owner
saying yes let's do this let's do this
with replay I thought let's do this and
so together there was a number of
different concepts okay is it the whole
game is it every palette it kind of it
was this year at the owners meetings one
of the most engaging ones I've been a
part of nine Jordan because here were
the other 32 coaches talking about ideas
what about this what's the consequence
of that like just think about like end
of the game on a Hail Mary okay like all
the contact that takes place on that is
that reviewable you know like all the
ones that coaches God of to say well
just throw a Hail Mary and see if they
can get a PI on it you know if there's
nine seconds left and there's still
another play and so here and people talk
about finding ways to go about attacking
something I thought it was awesome what
I ended up coming to is if it's the
ticky tacky call well I'm not sure if it
was you're not sure if it was then it's
not it's clear where there was like a
mistake that was made on the field and
this is a way to fix it and I think then
it's a good rule and why it's in play so
the ones that are could be or couldn't
be I don't think those are worth the
challenge they're too valuable sometimes
at that time out you know rich
immediately sure half the end of the
moment and so having that timeout you
can imagine what 20 or 30 seconds of
time means inside of a minute of a game
you'd better be pretty sure that the
flag that you Thrones you're going to be
you know very good chance that it's
going to get overturned last few minutes
left with Dan Quinn Falcons head coach
and defensive coordinator here
the Rich Eisen show when do we see Julio
Jones back on the field or for the first
time on the field with pads ready to
roll yeah fully fully blown member he's
running full speed and he's getting some
routes in with Matt and the guys I'll
say we're taking them all the way
through the process when he can hit all
the routes you know full speed no pain
and then they say he's just done a good
job he had a procedure that done he just
wanted to make sure all the healing and
everything was good so we've got time
we're probably still you know a couple
weeks away from him being you know added
top self but it's not too far away where
he'll be back there you know on the
field in a full-time capacity now what
what obviously you you can't inject
yourself into it but the contract stuff
I mean you know it's it's out there what
what what can you as the coach do well I
think what I try to do with it Julio or
you know there's no matter this year
with Deon and Grady is make sure that I
keep the lines of communication open as
their coach and I'm not involved on the
negotiating side anything from their
spot but I always wanted to make sure if
they ever you know something was on
their mind about they wanted to talk to
you about it but like in Grady's case we
had lots of conversations but none of it
was about his contract you know it was
about the team and about what we're
doing where's your training and you know
so many of those are just football
conversations that I enjoy with the
players so with Julio through the summer
it was the same thing not only is he a
great player rich but one of the things
that probably don't get they talk about
it as often as you do is I leave the
great teammate and all the guys not
everybody can be a great player in the
team but you can be a great teammate and
you have the players that are both their
multipliers is Julio doesn't just affect
the other wide receivers like still go
in and visit with the offensive line
they'll talk to your corner about a
technique that they were doing against
them so yeah this way to connect with
others behind the scenes that is very
unique and so great players but when you
combine both of them a great player but
also a great teammate his impact that he
has on the locker room it's significant
for him to be here and although he's a
fact immuno fool with the guys yet his
impact is just the same they would be
all the walkthroughs at night he's in
all the meetings so he's able to find
his way rich with the guys and it is one
of the things I really admire about him
off the field how he takes a real
intentional approach with his teammates
I know you got to get going
so let me just do two quick hitters with
you here Devonta Freeman how does he
look
together yes the energy and the that
Freeman has brought back into the game
it's contagious and you know some of
those people that year-round that always
bring the energy and you walk in like
hey pre what's up you ready to go on the
field the matchups are as hard as you
can imagine for the linebackers in the
safeties not just in the run game at the
pass game as well so he looks like
himself back full doing well so
Freeman's doing well and then you had a
follow-up one who was the second guy the
second thing is your quarterback Matt
Ryan I'm gonna lose my last minute with
you for me yep coach I've been trying to
change his nickname from Maddie ice to
the natural for years he finally told me
to move on let it go really like frozen
let it go I mean I'm really because I
was gonna try to appeal to you to just
call him that once in a meeting just see
if it sticks you know I mean like just
if it's head coach does it maybe maybe I
still have a chance here
yeah the natural nickname that has one
hell of a competitor a guy who will go
after you
that's Matt Ryan so I don't that's what
I don't think that match rule kind of
fits in because like if you lineup wrong
rich you're gonna get your ass rip so I
don't know if the natural to do that
well he's matric he's naturally
competitive
is basically you know I mean there's
many different ways to use this coach
you know but maybe hey just tell Dirk
cutter name a new play the natural and
see how it goes see how it's fantastic
thanks for the call coach appreciate it
we'll chat down the line have a good
rest of your summer that's Dan Quinn
Falcons head coach for more of the Rich
Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app